just to be allowed outdoors these people
must be able to prove they've either
been vaccinated or recently had covered
what's called in german that's why gay
regal or 2g rule
if not they're breaking the law and face
a fine of up to
1450 euros
ministers say the low uptake of the
vaccine and the high number of new cases
meant they had to act
the incidence among vaccinated people is
declining but it continues to rise
exponentially for the people who are not
vaccinated currently the incidence for
unvaccinated people in the 18 to 59 age
group is over 1700 so from monday there
will be a lockdown for the unvaccinated
here
across the border in the german state of
bavaria many communities are facing the
same threat there too ministers are
urging all the unvaccinated to get the
jab
in three german states the incidence of
covid is already more than 500 per 100
000 residents
in all three the 2g rule is either in
place or about to be implemented
but at a federal level there seems no
clear policy
unlike the situation in austria the
caretaker government here is in office
but not really in power the politicians
who matter are still trying to build a
majority in parliament
and while they argue over who gets which
ministerial job in the next few weeks
it's what kovid might do in the next few
days
that many people in wider society are
worrying about
this intensive care unit in munich is
one of many across the country which are
full of covid patients
with the prospect of more to come
if we look at the new infections
registered in the past two weeks we see
an increase from thirty thousand to
fifty thousand this also shows up in the
occupancy rates intensive care patients
have doubled and these fifty thousand
people who have tested positive now will
come to us this week or next week so the
future looks quite dark i would say and
we're quite worried about how we are
going to take care of all these people
official eu figures suggest around
two-thirds of the population have been
fully vaccinated
for them it means attendance at festive
events like these in vienna are no
problem
but for the third who remain
unvaccinated at least in austria for now
lockdowns are looming something similar
may soon be coming to germany dominick
kane al jazeera berlin